[Music]
um I have oh my God
I know as soon as I get these the first
person I DM them to directly it's like a
merch we have another drop too oh yeah
sorry we have another drop this is part
one sorry
oh this is the best day ever because
it's like Christmas I think
from them no one knew no one knew it's
CR it's Christmas but from a dark corner
of the room so yeah it's Christmas from
upstairs and be like I don't actually
like that eggnog I was like I won't
drink it I was like the other parent
like I knew I knew it was coming out for
Christmas but you know we just I kept it
you know you did good you didn't let the
kids have a big surprise so guess what
not only did he listen here's the
problem not only did he make a video he
made two one of them is 30 minutes long
the other one's 20 minutes long we're
skipping we're gonna skip around because
remember something about dating videos
there's a lot of quietling and repeating
but Dayton hypernova
oh my brother oh sorry by the way
um quick updates people that'll know um
the person who who our source on these
says that Dayton was on Facebook the
other day
hammered drunk and just rambling about
the new villain in his life is now his
younger brother his younger brother's
back when we got a new we got a new
brother yeah new brother by the way his
totally horrible right-wing brother
who's from San Francisco
just just so you guys know this man I
bet that guy really hates gay and
Traders he does
um my younger brother just got in town
um
uh it's rarely ever home and I'm
recording this yes yes because what he's
doing is what a normal child does moves
out they move out and then they visit
for holidays it is weird that he like
views that as like from a weird
perspective that's life yeah he doesn't
really come home a lot anymore you know
and it's like he's 30. he has a wife for
kids what do you want as a home I know
he sleeps in a bed with his wife
I sleep in a race car bed with my flakes
and I can't even hear out even my ears
right now because I'm my ears are
clogged from my psoriasis right now so I
can't even his ears are clogged because
no mercy is making a disgusting face
y stop
not what you think it's not what you
think it's not what you think it's not
what you think what do I think okay what
it is is that he has so much dead skin
that's what I thought it was also okay
sorry then we are on the same thing
oh
no no no Roy C you're wrong I thought
dead skin and wax oh [ __ ]
oh what but what is wax what if wax if
not creamy dead skin
the peanut butter of the ears
a psoriasis the peanut butter of the
ears
can you stop because there's flakes in
it it's chunky peanut butter
[Music]
oh I'm grossing myself out I gotta stop
ew I just thought about it oh okay sorry
guys you're being grossed stop
so I had to like disassociate handle oh
[ __ ] sorry Jeff had you were saying
sorry peanut butter ears yeah
that's everything
every time I go out every time I go
outside the dogs follow me I don't know
why
oh hidden hidden hidden hey hidden
Dayton
see that's what I mean I I just try to
turn closed caption on for these
segments because
secretly filming
wow it sounds like he sounds horrible he
sounds like he's laughing and having a
good time with his family can you
imagine being that guy it's so funny he
always builds these villains up and
they're always just like nice Ordinary
People
dude my favorite date and moment will
always be him filming his sister's
husband and the husband just turned
around going hi Dayton that was funny
you're right remember that when he was
filming him in the dad's like yo what up
Dayton OH he's like hey what's up Jaden
he's just like he saw me
what
what
not even a bottle okay I'm just trying
to make sure here we go
he's like I got him dead to rights
[Music]
hey Royce you don't gotta do it now but
I'm sending you for future dating videos
on a green screen for the overlay of
sneak increased oh I do like this
[Applause]
there you go
I need that too
yeah I need that three actually you know
it's just you know what just put it in
Show links just just put it that's
actually I'm looking at it yeah we need
all the skills honestly yeah you know
what pessies
see if you can find a plate uh uh a play
a playlist solution oh yeah that would
be fun illusion's always good for like a
passable transfers yeah I'm gonna have
my own folder on Steam deck of just
those overlays yeah okay that's a good
idea thank you
uh I will say this though can I make a
suggestion
I know you know everybody loves Skyrim
Oblivion is the most iconic ones though
with the little drum okay see what you
find
him
look in Show links I already found uh
aim destruction yes
this is so great I love this I love this
I love this one
um
wow I didn't know somebody just threw
these all up there there you go there it
is there it is I need all of these
I need all of those
that's the right one too from the right
game because that's the more iconic
I don't want to be overheard and it's
really hard to know how loud I am if
anything I'm probably too quiet talking
on this because you know what he's so
loud on the count of the peanut butter
in his ears what what
ah I'm just basically just
arises it's not just turning into a
[ __ ] Fallout ghoul ick [ __ ] man I
wish right now I'm just talking no
actually I wish now because he's gonna
last forever those things never they
last they live for hundreds of years hey
there smooth skin yeah I don't know
anyway it looks like he went into a
teleport device with a fly and he's
about halfway through the transition
you know what I like is choker so do you
do you like it you think he gets his
tags made at PetSmart voice is a guy
downstairs at your ears he was a caller
yeah
property of the Schultz's he didn't put
that on his family put it on with a bell
so they could hear him sneaking around
filming them you didn't even put a
tracker you think they put a tracker in
in his psoriasis medication
that's what he probably thinks yeah
Outreach attempt I made it to him
throughout the seven years are we
supposed to look at it like this by our
older brother yeah our older brother
passed away almost two years ago but
okay but here's a question Dean was he a
Nazi skinhead that used to beat you
a year and a half in that house and
let's see maybe uh from covid
um my parents went on like three wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait we didn't know he died of
covid we knew he died
but
the the initial cause of death was liver
failure that's what I thought that's you
could be lying I think Earl's just
smoking covert yeah no I know for a fat
because remember we heard the last time
we was drinking younger brother was
there they were talking about it was his
drinking and his liver failed he didn't
die of oh he's doing the he died of
covet because probably because his
parents or him were anti-vaxxers or
something
vacations during the lockdowns because
they had discount tickets for airfare or
whatever
so you're claiming your parents killed
your brother that's what this is
Darren's going on vacations came back
gave covet a day but Sherman didn't die
of kovid
I know family members I'm gonna email
them and if you're um they went like a
tula's vacations they got
coveted I don't know if you know this
Dayton but I'm very good friends with Dr
Phil's producer and what you're saying
is
Royce what
oh I got promoted
and he died the second time because his
immune system was so confident he died
the second time he died twice
three days later
he rose from the dead my parents went on
like three years okay
they had discount tickets for airfare or
whatever and they went and they got two
of those vacations they got
and they came back and they gave him
covid both times and he died the second
time because his immune system was so
compromised from his alcoholism
he didn't die of covet he died of it I
knew it I knew it he didn't die of covet
he died of liver failure
100 percent
100 percent
that he had been going to the hospital
regularly for his liver and his pancreas
anyway it's a long story and I don't
know how about him it was a 30 minute
video what else are you talking about
anyway my younger brother completely
ignored all of my Outreach to him during
the beginning was the only time I was
getting beat and should any Outreach he
may got to the point where I just
completely
deleted them from social media and I
stuck to Aunt rvm I bet you his younger
brother didn't even notice
that he deleted from social media he
probably did what he probably was like
relief is delightful yeah
I have no idea if I'm talking to him
he's accusing of his parents of killing
his brother
anyway I don't know who's recording this
I think I'm gonna do a part two now
whatever because you're not even you're
10 minutes like 19 minutes left
I don't want to make a video no you
don't want to you like okay yeah you
want to make two two long videos make
too long you know
why not three yeah
cool
God he's wearing a choker yeah I know
we've discussed the choker you discuss
how hot his choker is sneaking hold on
hold on hold on hold on I can't do the
audio but I can
hold on
sneak increase
all right all right okay no no no no no
no wow he that was oh my God
that was a lot of pocket time guys
I can't really hear them
outside by an open window and I can't
really hear
I can hear my brother again on the count
of the peanut butter peanut butter yes
sir you know that's all we're gonna call
them now is peanut butter ears he has a
new name now used to be earl now it's
peanut butter here very close right now
from my psoriasis is getting in my ear
canal whatever and like both my ears
so anyway I can't really [ __ ] hear
right now okay that means I also can't
hear how well how they're quiet I'm
talking about I don't even know that um
so I have no idea if it's audible on the
video or not but anyways down there
outside on the patio back in the
backyard
what's basically these people are
completely ignoring everything that
happened to me oh they're very rare
occasional
ignoring things that happened to you 10
years ago according to you exactly look
at him
uh what I love her
look at what a vision of beauty
for anyone identifying on that side of
the spectrum of the gender and she's a
major tomboy he's taught me that if you
can't hear you can't be heard
trans Daredevil over here like
so it's very messed up it's a tomboy
who's transphobic
and you know she just she's that you
know her sister
is a tomboy who's transphobic married to
a black guy by the way
football playing type
excuse me her husband is a what is that
what we're calling him now football
playing types
what was that
super racist is without again of course
so that's very messed up it's a tomboy
who's transphobic
and you know she just she's that you
know
football playing type
or something which is fine in itself but
it's ridiculous to be that Macho and
intolerant
if I didn't they have two Pride flags
and usually do wasn't enough dude they
needed the whole house needed to be a
pride flag
like the White House person getting beat
in my own home unless you smearing scum
all over the front door of your house
for protection from the gay Mafia would
you accept peanut butter
after it kept happening over and over
and she never provided any kind of right
you could always hear them because
they're always walking in heels they
said they can't ever sneak up on you
they can't sneak up because every time
one of them sees another one they're
like yes oh the game offi is here I
could hear him I could hear them
and she has a rainbow two rainbow Flags
right on her house right making her
windows or what I don't know
she's pretending to be Pro lgbtq
basically just dig it okay hear me out
on this
I understand people pretending to be
something or not just so that they you
know blend in you know gonna rest
why why would you buy two
right like now you're spending extra
money on the grift why I think one is
good enough then you have everybody
fooled the irony of Trans State and
hypernova saying he doesn't like when
people pretend to be something they're
not
is not lost on me I just want to be
clear it's not lost on me PDQ basically
just dig it
disgusting her husband's a bigot they
did two of them he's a football playing
type that's the football player type
harass me together he's a black guy of
course he's a bigot I've seen him dating
I've seen him for five seconds in one of
your videos and all he did was say hello
to you hey what update you freaking out
you panicked
and by the way he was there helping his
dad carry some stuff remember that he
was being helpful don't worry I got it
this house
um it wasn't quite a year ago it was
in December of last year there you
they they
um they bullied me together right in
front of my parents and they cussed me
out both of them like crazy over me
accusing the skinhead for all of the
violence
so they were like so let me get this
straight your family was having another
one of their their attempts at a lovely
get-together yes and you started with
[ __ ] again about the the long dead
skinhead in the beatings and all this
nonsense and they just finally went shot
up and then you start every story like I
was there I was minding my own business
and again whatever I just started
yelling at me and then again ironically
the literal dead skin head is him his
head is filled with dead skin in his
ears and everything about him no you are
the dead you're the dead skin head
doing crazy things like
I'm not surprised or I
that might surprise that
um they felt that way about you about
you because of the kind of person you
are like what kind of person am I
there's nothing about me even slightly I
never once instigated to get people in
the first place there's nothing I did to
even get beat I the only times I um
is even being
confrontational at the skinhead was when
you broke a wine glass over his head on
Christmas Eve bro remember that we
played it on this show dude remember
when you ruined the lovely high-end
dinner at Outback Steakhouse oh my God
it was they were they were so happy to
be there too because they really liked
Outback we're having a lovely time yep
that was like that's a big night out in
Dayton Ohio with the family at the
Outback in a [ __ ] blooming onion and
then you just couldn't help yourself
remember when he got mad because his dad
would normally the pizza from the place
he liked the [ __ ] skinhead the only
chance I was even confrontational I
meant the beatings was when he was
shouting at my parents or if parents
were being shouted at him they were like
the person that that I've seen on video
shout out your parents the most is you
by the way your mom specifically
energies you know like in their 70s
basically and
shouting like crazy violently being
dangerous towards him and I stepped in
the first couple of times I got beat and
I get bro the problem with Danish is
that it we know his lore so we know how
all this is [ __ ] the person who goes
we've we've seen him scream quiet now
but when his brother wasn't around we
see him scream at the top of his lungs
to his mom well not only that I remember
how many times have we seen him get
arrested or always arrested like the
cops come and the mental health people
come and they all know him they all know
it it's it's that that chick cop the
social service chick cop knew him
immediately hey Dayton what's going on
how are you probably his girlfriend
I think because I don't think my mom's
home right now I think she wants to
I don't know I think she'll she I think
she went to they're going on vacation
hold on like basically ignore everything
that happened
and going on vacation all of them
together and they're not ignoring
everything that happened he your brother
died over a year ago
and they're they're trying to move on I
mean what do you want from them
well free free food free room and board
and a hundred dollars a week to do
nothing isn't enough no he needs more he
needs more so my mom needs reparations
on top of that and Q-tips probably take
the car over to it to a a rental place
to get another car to rent to take so I
guess that's what we usually would do
it's huge the Andrew Cuomo Q Tips ah you
know I just I'm waiting on those they're
actually coming in the mail
hey uh you see a long box
movie you're trying to be a tube it says
it might be one of those you know like
the ones that the engineers put
blueprints in it says that SC Johnson
wax on it
anyway
um so most likely it's his girlfriend
out there talking when I'm assuming
along with my sister and
if that's true then basically they
uh there's most likely my brother is I'm
kind of guest here I don't know if he's
gonna
try to even speak to me at all because I
wouldn't I wouldn't either you're
terrible you're the worst person I've
ever seen you're a person I would
absolutely avoid at all and any chance I
got I wouldn't see you you're the person
that I go ah [ __ ] he's coming [ __ ] why
would anybody speak to him he can't hear
it
now there's a lot of new people here on
Rumble here and I want I want to you
they're interested but they don't
understand Dayton hypernova is a
gentleman that we have been excuse me a
lady that we have been covering for
three years now right maybe three four
long time and he's somebody that was
found organically on YouTube and if if
you go to our ROTC Clips Channel on
YouTube or actually you don't need to
it's on Rumble our Eclipse up there too
just search Dayton hypernova we have an
entire playlist put together of this
guy's story is insane
um he's accused his brother being the
skinhead of being a Nazi I can't even go
through the whole thing all I'll tell
you is if you have any free time throw
that bad boy out on the background it's
in order and you'll understand what
we're talking about
his girlfriend is around
so anyway
I'm really sick and but it's just
absolutely disturbing in the old world
kind of enabling
family that is awful
oh he's scared someone walked up again
someone walked up again someone walked
up again
he's gonna sneak bonus though
okay end of first video I'll tell you
what we'll do we'll do we'll do we'll do
the next video
here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do the next video which by
the way is also very fun the next video
we're gonna do tomorrow on our patreon
show